Let me summarize some observations that we made in this unit about the complexity of models.
For instance, in the SIR and SEIR models, we worked with fractional population numbers.
We didn't care whether or not the numbers of persons are integers.
In the SEIR model, we used an average amount of latency.
We did not build in a fix delay and we assumed perfect mixing.
There is no geographical distribution, there is no age distribution, there are no isolated towns.
One of the advantages of the simple models we looked at in this unit is that we were able to derive
general statements such as the existence of Herd Immunity.
Of course, we have to be careful.
A general statement about a cartoonish model may not be that helpful, and the simple equations
that we've got from these models are helpful in may ways.
For instance, when it comes to working with implicit methods such as the big foot Euler method.